what's your first week working on a new
idea like like what are you
if you've gotten this idea while you're
in traffic or wherever it is standing
line at the supermarket
but then you're actually okay i'm gonna
invest time in this what's it like
uh it's just notes so i'm very organized
disorganized
um it's it's it's a notebook
where i am just i'm writing either lines
of dialogue
ideas for a scene something about a
character
character breakdown any number of things
that i think are a theme
something that i want somebody to say i
don't even know what character would say
it but this is a line that i want
something where it's happening it's that
it's a bunch of that i don't do the note
card thing
i don't i will i will write a series of
notes i might even from those notes like
i'll fill up one of those
like those black i don't know if i have
any of those black notebooks you know
the things that
in seven where the guy used to make all
his notes right one of those
i'll fill one of those up and i might
write a draft out of that that draft
will suck
but i have something and then i might
then make an
outline from the draft so i've got notes
that i turn into a draft that i will
then turn into an outline defined
structure i don't like to
structure first because i'm not as
interested in plot i'm
i'm really not that interested in plot
at all i'm much more interested in
character and theme and so it's about um
ideas and how i'm trying to express
those ideas whether it's through
characters actions or their context or
whatever and so i found that if i tried
to impose structure first which is what
i think of as
as being is a structural thing that then
i get too focused
on the mechanics of plot which i don't
care about at all
i want it to be about character and
characters
journey however you want to describe it
so that's why outline actually comes for
me
after i've written a draft so that i can
then okay here are all these ideas are
there a way i can structure these ideas
now okay if that makes sense so it's
not an efficient way like if i was like
on for hire for a script i probably
couldn't do it that way but i'm
nobody's knocking on my door to do that
paid me a bunch of money to write a
script for them
so this way allows me to
to hold on to the things that i think
are more important because if i'm
worried about
these kind of story beats and steps
and because american movies are all
about causality this causes this causes
this causes this
um then i might lose the character
because if the character is doing things
that are contradictory there's not a
clear causality between them
that might be way more interesting than
if there is
um so that's kind of the way whether
that happens over a week i don't know
i've got two kids now who the hell knows
how long it'll take me to get to those
places it might get me i might get to a
draft in a week but i kind of doubt it
um that first week is probably just
going to be notes notes notes notes
notes
and trying to figure out who it is and
then when you actually get a first draft
down
are you doing the sort of putting it
away and then looking at it again
yeah that's generally what i found is
the best
thing it's um i want to i want to look
at it with fresh eyes
i'm not sending it to anybody yet
because it's not good enough yet
you don't want to waste people's time
and i don't want to get a bunch of notes
from
i don't want to waste their time and i
also don't want to get a bunch of notes
for stuff that i'll
of course i know what's wrong with it
right after i look at it a second time
um so it's don't look at it for
whatever a couple weeks a month
something like that
and then go back in and look at it and
hopefully do a pretty significant
teardown
of it pieces of it will survive but it
should be a pretty significant teardown
because the first thing shouldn't be
very good it should
um you're trying to get some ideas out
uh you're trying to work around those
ideas
but um it's not going to be anywhere
near what the finished product
i mean that first draft of faith from 10
years ago was vastly different than
the thing the movie that we shot you
still have it
yeah somewhere it's on a thumb drive
somewhere
yeah where did you write it
i did the very cliched thing
this is before i had kids so i could do
this as i i uh
went to i went up the coast and and just
rented a hotel for like two or three
days
and banged out the first draft i mean i
had a whole bunch of it sort of worked
out so it wasn't like a what's my idea
and three days later i had a finished
draft of the script i had a whole bunch
of notes and stuff that i was working
from but yeah
did you say it like an ocean view hotel
no i don't have the money to afford that
but it was by the ocean here oh it
sounds so romantic
yeah yeah yeah i know i did that but
yeah
good luck to me convincing my wife to
let me do that again now leave her with
two kids so i can go right
i don't think that's going to happen did
you do it with a laptop or did you get
right into it yeah no yeah
i'm too lazy i'm too lazy to do long
form i've
uh that was one thing that like i had
final draft
very early on when i was still an
undergrad and i've just gotten used to
writing that way
was the was going back to that 10-year
hotel stay was that
taking clock worth it in terms of it
actually got you to finish it because
you're like i'm here i paid for this
yeah i know it helped but that that
it helped i'm sure i can't remember it
so long ago
um but it was also like it was good to
just
um that was just the thing i was there
to do
it was just that you know nothing else
um it was a good feeling and also the
the idea
felt like you have times when you're
reaching for the idea like you're
writing and but you're still reaching
for the idea
the idea was like close enough to where
i could do it in
that three days time you know get it out
there's other scripts or
the idea is not close enough to where i
wouldn't be able to get it all out in
three days time
if that makes any sense it does yeah
that's interesting
how many drafts of faith did you write
before you sent it to your producer
mike i had probably written
three maybe four something like that
i want to say i'd have to go back and
look but i want to say it was three or
four drafts
um and it's a yeah like i said it's a
vastly different script than the one
um that we ended up shooting that
thematically it's the same uh
structurally and character-wise it's a
little bit different
so three or four drafts in you send it
to him
what's his time frame for getting back
to you what were the notes
uh he got back to me
probably within three weeks
something like that um again i won't
make it sound like i just sent it to him
like
there was plenty of people i sent it to
who didn't respond
but it was kind of in his wheelhouse
like it's he
was he told me when he was like 14 he
was thinking about being a priest
oh wow um but then girls
and so then you know girls happen to be
yeah exactly
um and um
his his response i mean he responded the
script he said
i like the way it's dealing with these
kinds of um
with issue these kinds of issues but no
judgment to the characters
um and then he had a few ideas for
the ending as i recall or i don't know
so then we
we talked on the phone about it and um
he suggested i do another like scene
outline so i did a scene outline and
then he came out to la because
he was here he's a new york based
producer
he was here because one of his films was
i was around the independent spirit
awards i remember that
and one of his films was nominated for i
think was one of the actors or something
and so then we got to meet and talk
face-to-face and he
suggested a big change i originally the
story was
actually divided between two characters
whose two different stories going on and
he suggested just to
simplify it to just focus on one
character for a number of reasons he
said don't change
the the again the themes
the ideas all that stuff stays the same
you just got to simplify the story so
it's just
one person's story so i did that
and he was he responded really
positively to that rewrite
and so then we were kind of off and
running in terms of
then trying to generate interest we
ended up out i ended up out in new york
through uh with ifp
um they had a this kind of screenplay
what did they call it this program
that's emergency emerging
storytellers where they selected it was
a pretty competitive program they only
select x number of scripts and then we
got to meet
uh with like sony classics and
i don't remember a bunch of different
companies you know trying to generate
interest see if you can get any money we
didn't get any money
um but uh but it was a really good thing
and and um and then it was i
rewrote a couple more drafts and then
eventually we got there do you think the
themes
in faith are ones that people can relate
to
even if they're you know
non-denominational they're not part of a
church
even if they don't consider themselves
religious yeah i mean i think
i i think the audience for it will
probably
be more people who consider themselves
agnostic
um more so than well i don't know
god sorry um
i think the audience four will probably
be people who consider themselves
uh agnostic i mean i don't know we there
might be some
um some regular church-goers who
who are interested in it too um but yeah
i mean especially people who
maybe went to church as when they were
kids
and now aren't as connected to it i
think they probably will respond to it
um but we'll see i don't know i mean
that's a big thing now is like you
you're supposed to figure out who your
audience is beforehand right
i'm not i'm not as comfortable with that
just because i feel like you're um
i want to make the thing
i want to make the thing that's in my
head that i think is interesting without
[Music]
thinking about who else is going to find
it interesting
not because i don't think or don't want
anybody else to find it interesting
but i'm too i'm worried that if i focus
too much on what other people are
thinking about it then i'll lose the
thread
of what's interesting about it to me the
hope is
that if it's interesting to me it's
going to be interesting to
other people if we do it well enough
and that will
hopefully be enough to get in a big
enough audience to
make the movie worthwhile but
who knows um i i just i like the
i know several people who are sort of
involved in this like marketing and
distribution
before you make the movie and i
understand it
because of these things we've been
talking about in terms of the lack of
funding and trying to
get your money back from a movie i
completely understand it but just as a
as the writer director in me is like i
i can't think about that stuff or else
all of a sudden you're worried about
this choice and how it fits in the film
you're not worried about if it fits in
the
the the world of the film you're worried
about how other people are going to
respond to it and i just
i it's anathema to me i just i can't
i don't want to do it so i don't know
we'll see
you know you you uh you hope you hope
that you've done something that enough
people will respond to because there's
you know people have um put their faith
in you and
and um put some money behind the movie
and
and so um you don't want to disappoint
him you wanted to
you want that faith to be rewarded
so here's hoping
you